[APPLAUSE]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey, everyone.
I'm John McCutchan.
TODD TURNIDGE:
I'm Todd Turnidge.
We're both developers
on the Dart VM team.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, and we
really care about the developer
experience, so we're
really excited today
to talk to you more about
Hot Reload and a new feature
that you haven't
seen yet, Rewind.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
You saw some nice demos of
that with Eric's stuff already.
We're going to go a little
more in-depth on them,
and maybe a little
slower on some of that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
So what we're really
here to talk about today
is changing the way you
change your Dart code.
And so we're going to
start off with two demos.
We're going to show Hot
Reload, and then we're
going to show Rewind.
So let's just get
straight into the demo.
So here I am in Adam.
And I have the Flutter
Gallery running on the side.
You're already familiar
with Flutter Gallery.
So what I've got here
on the left-hand side
is the source code
for the calculator
demo inside the gallery.
So this is your
standard calculator--
you know, add, subtract,
multiply, divide, 0 through 9.
And as you saw, Eric showed
that you could very quickly
redesign your UI.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm just
going to add 10, 11, and
12 to the calculator.
TODD TURNIDGE: So
he's have just copying
this little bit
of code, and he's
going to change the 7, 8 and
9 keys to 10, 11, and 12, keys
and then hit reload,
and there you go.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And
as you saw before,
you could also-- maybe
you want to change
the color of the buttons.
You can do that.
TODD TURNIDGE:
Now, at the bottom
here, it says reloaded
seven of 440 libraries.
Want to say what's
going on there?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, so what we're
doing in the backend
of the VM is we're
actually figuring out which one
of your libraries have changed
or are transitively
affected by the change,
and we only reload those.
And so this reload
that we just did
there took 285
milliseconds, and we only
reloaded seven of
about 440 libraries.
TODD TURNIDGE: So let's talk
about what 285 milliseconds
means.
I mean, when you're developing,
if something takes 2 minutes,
you go away and you do something
else, you get distracted,
whatever.
285 milliseconds,
as you saw, you're
able to make change after change
after change and your tools
aren't getting in your way.
You've got a nice,
tight development cycle.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: This
is the true time
from the moment I pressed
the request for the reload
all the way until the frame
is rendered on the device.
We're not skipping
anything here.
This is the true time from when
you press the button in your ID
to when you can visually
see it in the app.
TODD TURNIDGE: And when did we
start working on that, like,
back in March or something?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: May.
TODD TURNIDGE: May, yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's been one fun summer.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So let's
take it a little bit further,
and why don't we add the
mod operator to calculator?
We're all developers,
we all have mod.
For some reason, calculators
have forgotten about it.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and I added a new key.
And I'm going to
ignore this error here
that the analyzer is warning
me about, telling me--
TODD TURNIDGE:
Yeah, forget that.
You're smarter
than the analyzer.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, handle mod tap.
That's not implemented.
And as you can see,
we get this red widget
of death, which is what
happens when one of your
build functions inside
your Flutter app
ends up throwing an exception.
TODD TURNIDGE: Except death
is now in quotes, right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
because in the Reload world,
we can bring your app
right back to life.
So I'll just start by copying
the implementation of plus,
and I'll just rename it to mod.
TODD TURNIDGE: So
now we're not just
changing little bits of code,
we're adding new functions.
We can add new classes.
We can add new lots of things.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You can
import new libraries,
you can unimport libraries,
you can delete classes.
There's lots of things
you can do here.
TODD TURNIDGE: But now
you should actually
get something in our
accumulator here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, all
right, so let's do, like--
TODD TURNIDGE: 8
times 11, maybe.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, let's
somehow clear that out.
That might get too big.
All right, so there's
the 10 button working.
Now, I've wired up
mod to do something,
but it's really just
going to do plus.
All right, the button works, but
let's take it one step further
and actually finish the
implementation of mod
in the calculator.
So you could see here that
the way the calculator is
structured is that you
pass in the operation kind
when the button is pressed.
So I'll just go ahead and say,
I want to do a mod operation.
And here's the static
analyzer telling me,
hey, there is no mod
defined for this ENUM.
TODD TURNIDGE: At this
point, the workflow sort
of looks like you
follow the bread crumbs
that the analyzer left
you until, as Kevin
was talking about earlier,
the red squiggles all go away.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
So what I've done
is I've added mod to
the ENUM, and that's
OK in a Reloaded world.
But now I'm just
going to follow along,
and there's many
switch statements
that I forgot to
include mod for.
So this is what
the mod operation
will look like on the screen.
Or percent.
Just use the analyzer here.
Now, down here, this is handling
addition and subtraction.
TODD TURNIDGE: So mod is like
multiplication and division,
so it will handle the same way.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Now, down here is
where I'll actually
go ahead and implement
mod, and Todd
will talk about what I'm doing.
TODD TURNIDGE: I think we
should see if Eric can actually
add the 10 and 11 and 12 key
to the calculator for real,
so save us all this time.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
TODD TURNIDGE: Is it looking
clean, or not quite yet?
He's going to implement the
mod operator-- current value
mod equals x number.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And
we'll put an else there.
OK, just do reload.
TODD TURNIDGE: Boom.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There's
no visual change here,
but that reload took
265 milliseconds.
TODD TURNIDGE: So
essentially instant.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let's see.
All right, OK.
It looks like it's working.
There it is.
So what we've seen
here is more than just
editing the body of a function.
We added methods,
we crashed our app,
we brought the app back to life,
we added a new ENUM definition,
and we fully implemented
mod in this calculator,
never restarting it.
TODD TURNIDGE: We kept
our state the whole time.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And
each step along the way
took about 285 milliseconds.
So there's no more
"xkcd" compiling
memes in the Flutter world.
All right, so that's
the Hot Reload demo.
Todd's going to
talk about Rewind.
TODD TURNIDGE: All
right, so Rewind
is a feature that
we're working on that
plays very nicely with Reload.
It's not quite
implemented in Flutter
yet, so I'm going to demo
it on just a standalone Dart
VM today, but it
will be coming soon.
I've written a text
adventure game.
Those of you who've seen
my demos in past years
know I always have written
a text adventure game.
All right, so you're in
a mysterious chamber.
There's an exit to the west.
A deadly mousetrap lies nearby.
So I'm going to go attach the
Observatory debugger to this.
Let's add a tab and
go to local host.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So
what is Observatory?
TODD TURNIDGE:
Observatory is a set
of tools that come
bundled in with Flutter
or with the Dart VM that allow
you to do just a ton of stuff.
Like what kinds of stuff?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: CPU profiling,
allocation profiling.
We have a new timeline
feature this year.
Debugging.
TODD TURNIDGE: In this case,
I'm going to use the debugger,
and I'm going to tell it to
turn on break on exception
so that if I hit an
exception while I'm
running my text adventure game,
it will pop into the debugger.
Now, do you think I'm likely
to hit an exception in my game?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I've seen
this demo before, Todd.
You're definitely going
to throw an exception.
TODD TURNIDGE: So I'm going to
go west, I'm going to go south.
I'm going to take the oil can.
Now, the oil can can be
used to oil an object
to make it not rusty, like
the rusty revolver, which
I'm not holding.
And I'm not holding a revolver.
And uh-oh, I've gotten
this no such method.
All right, so you run
into no such methods a lot
if you're a Dart developer,
and usually it means what?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Your
program is dead.
TODD TURNIDGE: You restart
your program and try again.
And you have to sort of
do this post-mortem thing.
So let's look at this
stack trace here.
We've got object no
such method, called
by another no such method,
called by my do command.
And what the Rewind
feature does is
it allows us to take
any function call
and rewind back to the
call site that called it
so that then we're sort
of going back in time
and we can run it again.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Now, what happens
if there's side effects?
TODD TURNIDGE: If
there's side effects,
we don't undo the side effects.
So this works pretty well
with a function that's
relatively side effect-free.
You can go back and sort
of walk through the steps
again to see why you crashed.
So I can rewind, and I
could rewind again, even.
I could see, oh, I'm here.
I'm doing this thing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the
program has actually
moved its execution point
back to this function.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, I'm
just about to the call.
If I want to do the call
again, I can just continue
and I can hit my
exception again, you know?
Or I could rewind and I could
step back into the function.
So let's actually use
this for some purpose.
I'm looking at my
code and I'm like,
boy, I wonder what the value
of the item 2 is there.
So I'm going to go to
Emacs, king of editors,
and I'm going to print
value is $ the item 2.
So I'm just adding
some code in here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's classic
[INAUDIBLE] debugging.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yep.
I'll save it.
Now I'll go back over
here and I'll reload.
So I've reloaded the code.
If I start rewinding,
though, I see
that I still have the
old code and do command.
That's kind of bad.
Well, it's because
I was in the middle
of running that function.
I was in the middle of
running the old code.
In order to get the
new code, I need
to enter the
function again, which
means I need to rewind
one more and go back in.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We'll talk
a little bit more about that
later on in the talk.
TODD TURNIDGE: So I
rewind, and now I'm
going to just step
into do command.
And you notice the pink
along the edge there?
That's code coverage.
This is the first time
we're in this function now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: This
version of the function.
TODD TURNIDGE: This
And if I look down here, I see
that the printer will be done,
so let's just continue and see
what the value could possibly
have been.
I hit the exception again.
Go back over here to
my text adventure game.
It says, oh, the value is null.
All right, I have a
null in my program.
Let's just fix this thing.
So if the item 2-- I
have to sing when I code.
It's really hard for people
in my office-- equals null,
then-- John wears
headphones a lot, actually.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
noise-canceling.
TODD TURNIDGE: And
then so if it's null,
I'm going to give them
some sort of a message.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: How about
say, "You can't oil that."
TODD TURNIDGE: You can't--
I'll say, "You can't oil that."
I'm going to say,
"You cannot oil that!"
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
Be verbose.
TODD TURNIDGE: Exclamation.
This is my game.
So I'm going to go back here,
and I'm going to reload this.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So we got
to rewind past the point--
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, so
let's start rewinding up
frames and rewinding up frames.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And
could you rewind, like,
with an n number of frames?
TODD TURNIDGE: You can say
rewind three, or something
if you want.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Nice.
TODD TURNIDGE: And that works.
And so let's rewind
one more and step in.
And now it looks like--
I have to sing again.
Yeah, there's this "You
cannot oil that" right there,
so what do you say we continue
the program and see if it's all
good?
Back here.
And it says, "You
cannot oil that."
So I fixed my program.
This is called fix and
continue debugging.
We're able to--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
the combination of--
[APPLAUSE]
TODD TURNIDGE: So
the combination
of Reload plus being able
to just go a little bit back
in time means that
you can get yourself
into a weird, bad
neighborhood of your program,
someplace where before you
just got knocked in the head
and you had all
your stuff stolen.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, you
wake up the next morning,
you're like, what happened?
TODD TURNIDGE: So instead, while
you're there, and you can say,
I'm going to make this right.
And you have, sort of,
your groundhog's day moment
where you just redo
events again and again
until you get it right.
Fix your problem
and then you go on
so you don't need to go through
your 15 minutes of setup
that it took.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, I mean, Todd
did, like, three
actions here, right?
West, south, take the oil can.
But in a larger
app, you might be,
like, 10 pages deep
into your mobile app,
your app has downloaded a bunch
of assets off the network,
and getting back to the
state to reproduce the bug
may take a minute or two.
But with Rewind and
Reload combined,
you can just hang out
right around the place
where your bug is.
TODD TURNIDGE: All right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
OK, so we've just
given you a demo of Hot Reload
and Rewind combined, but let's
take a step back and just
look at what this new death
cycle looks like.
TODD TURNIDGE: All right,
so you're programming,
and occasionally when
you're programming,
you find a problem
with your program.
We both found problems.
He had a function he called
that wasn't in his program,
for example.
He got this red screen.
And so we changed our program.
We just reload.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
and then what happens,
the VM gets the reload
request, it determines
which libraries have
changed, and then it
just reloads those libraries.
TODD TURNIDGE: Now,
sometimes the reload
won't work for
some reason, right?
Like, maybe you have some--
it's not really Dart code
you've put into the
file or something.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, maybe
you pasted some JavaScript
in there.
TODD TURNIDGE:
What happens then?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's safe.
We detect at reload time if the
reload is acceptable to apply
or not.
And if we decide that
it can't be applied,
we just put the old
code back in place
and we just let your
program continue as it was.
TODD TURNIDGE: We want
to take this cycle
and make it as tight
as we possibly can.
Remove as much of this
annoyance of development.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So now,
for Flutter applications,
we follow up Reload with
a couple extra steps.
The first is that
we ask the Flutter
app to reassemble itself.
And what this means practically
speaking is just all of your
build methods get re-invoked.
So the new widget tree gets
passed down to the renderer,
and that gets rendered
on the screen.
And we just follow that up
again with a forced frame.
So this is how we get the
Flutter app after reloading
the code to reassemble the UI.
TODD TURNIDGE: And the
way the Flutter framework
is structured-- we
don't go into it-- it's
particularly well-suited to work
well with Reload in this case.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I
mean, the Flutter framework
is functional, right?
And what we're talking about is
updating the body of functions.
TODD TURNIDGE: OK, it helps
to have just a little bit
of intuition about how
Reload works if you're
going to be doing
development against it
so that you're not surprised.
First let's talk about, sort
of, naming and identity.
I have some set of code
that I'm reloading,
and when I load it
in, I get a library.
And the library
might have some URL.
It will replace whatever
original library
had the same URL.
So the library's URL is
important for determining
what the replacement
is for the original.
In the same way, if I have
some class with the same name
as a class that
existed before, and it
happens to be in
the same library,
then we replace that class.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's fairly
intuitive as a developer.
I mean, libraries are
loaded in Dart by URL,
and we just keep these naming
and identities along the way.
Now, the most common
question we've
had from all of the developers
who've been playing around
with Hot Reload for a while is
what happens to my static data?
And if you look at the
top of the slide here,
you can see that
there's this list x,
and it has this initializing
expression of just a list of 1,
2, 3.
Now, the VM is only going to
run this initializing expression
once.
And it depends-- like,
when your program first
accesses x, that's when the
initializing expression is
going to be run.
TODD TURNIDGE: So if we did
it once before our reload--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It
would be 1, 2, 3.
But if you reload it
first and then accessed x,
you would get 4, 5, 6
as the initial value.
And the key takeaway here
is that code is reloaded,
but data isn't.
So x does not
automatically update,
but luckily you have a
debugger, and you can just
go into the debugger and change
x to be whatever you want.
TODD TURNIDGE: Basically, you
keep your heap across reloads.
So whatever is there is there.
All right, so let's talk
about function calls.
We saw a little bit about
this in the adventure demo.
So we have some activations
on our call stack.
I call main, it calls
some other functions,
and we activate a reload.
We trigger a reload.
After the point of the
reload, all new function calls
will use the new code.
But the existing--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
the existing code
is going to stay there
and run until it comes off
the stack, which is where
Rewind becomes so powerful.
TODD TURNIDGE: Right.
So if we called Foo
recursively here,
we'd have a new version of Foo
on the stack at the same time
as an old version of Foo.
And so that's why
yeah, again, you
need Rewind sometimes
because if you
want to force executing
the new version of the code
during a debugging session.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So when
Dart was first designed,
one of the explicit
design goals was
to not allow you to change
the shape of an instance.
TODD TURNIDGE: And by shape
we mean the number of fields.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: How many
fields is in your class?
That is locked down the
moment your program runs.
But in a Reload world and in
this live development world
that we have today,
we want to support
changing the shape of instances
while your program are running.
So you can add a
new field in Reload.
And what we do is we end
up going through the heap,
we find every instance of
that class, we grow it,
and we put null in to
where that new field is.
And deleting works the same
way except we just shrink it.
So we just scan
across the heap, we
find every instance of
the class, shrink it down,
and whatever values
were in those fields
in those instances,
they're just garbage
and the GC will take
care of them for you.
Renaming fields
is not supported.
It's just treated
like a deletion
followed by an addition.
TODD TURNIDGE:
Yeah, and ID could
maybe-- if we have enough
context, we could do renames,
but for now, it's just
additions and deletions.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: But
reordering works fine.
Like we use URLs
and class names,
we use field names for
matching and pairing them up.
So if your class
goes from listing
the fields as x, y, z to z,
y, x, everything will be fine.
TODD TURNIDGE: We'll just swap
them all around in memory.
OK, anonymous closures.
In bold here you see
an anonymous closure
that is adding two numbers.
And after reload, maybe
it subtracts two numbers.
Well, the closures get
captured at the time
that they're created,
so it's not like
just because you did a reload
that this closure that you
created is going to change.
It will continue to be
plus after the reload,
even though you've changed it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So
this means that you
could end up in a state
where they're both alive.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, you could
easily have, like, essentially,
two anonymous closures, which
are, in some sense, the same.
They're created at the
same point your program,
but they're different
because they were
created at different times.
It's just part of
how closures work.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Anonymous closures.
TODD TURNIDGE:
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Now,
tear-off closures,
these are like methods that
are attached to an instance.
These always use
the latest code,
and this is because when you
invoke a tear-off closure,
there's a level of indirection
that it steps through where
it's really attached to
the name of the method
and not the source code that
was in the method at the time.
So in this code example
on the slide here,
you can see that I first start
off with my onTap printing 1,
I make a tear-off closure, I
reload, and now it prints 2.
I take another
tear-off closure, now
both of these tear-off
closures print 2.
TODD TURNIDGE: This
works pretty nicely
when you're doing reload
as part of your development
cycle, these tear-off closures.
They just sort of
update themselves.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Like
handle mod tap earlier--
that's a tear-off closure.
So every time I make a
change to handle mod tap,
the app is going to
respect that and see that.
So Dart now supports
live programming with
less-than-1-second edit refresh
cycle on mobile devices.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, we've
got this Rewind feature coming
soon, which is going
to give you the ability
to fix and continue.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So
yeah, try Flutter today.
We're really excited for
you guys to try it out.
Just finally, we just want to
say that this wasn't just Todd
and I working on this.
Ryan, who was also
on the VM team,
and Ian Hickson, who's
on the Flutter team,
have been very important
making this happen, as well
as many other
people on both teams
for bug reports and fixes.
Thank you.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, thanks.
SPEAKER 3: So you guys
did an excellent job
of finishing in time to do a
little Q&A if you would like.
We have a couple minutes
while they get set up.
Do you guys want to
answer some questions?
TODD TURNIDGE: I'd love
to answer some questions.
SPEAKER 3: I like just putting
you on the spot like that.
Is that OK?
TODD TURNIDGE: No, that's fine.
SPEAKER 3: You guys
have any questions?
SPEAKER 4: I'm waiting for,
like, the "SNL" thing like,
so what you guys
did was awesome.
Is that a question?
SPEAKER 3: How awesome?
SPEAKER 4: How awesome, exactly?
Is this feature cool,
or the coolest feature?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You guys
want to just grab us out
of the context, you
can do that, too.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah
that's also OK.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, I
think we've got a question.
TODD TURNIDGE: OK.
AUDIENCE: There is a
question about memory leaks
and how many memory
[INAUDIBLE] for example,
leaks so much, and
especially on Linux.
SPEAKER 3: Could you
repeat the question first?
TODD TURNIDGE:
Yeah, he was asking
if we have problems
with memory leaks.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hot reload--
TODD TURNIDGE: Is
your thing still on?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Thank you, it's not.
Hot reload is implemented and
the VM does not leak memory.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah, we create
all these new libraries,
and then the old libraries,
we just unlink them
and the GC takes care of them.
I mean, all of our
libraries and code and stuff
is all in the heap, and so once
we're not using it anymore,
like on the call
stack, it goes away.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
those old code objects
will just be GC'd after
the activation exits.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And about Flutter
framework, Flutter applications
in comparison with
native applications,
what about memory and CPU?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We're
not the right people
to answer that question.
SPEAKER 4: Find Eric
and Seth and you
can talk about that with them.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We work
on the VM and reload.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How much
of that functionality
can be reused for handlers
dot VM, [INAUDIBLE]?
Is there something
that's going to come to--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh,
it's already supported.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SPEAKER 4: The
question was does this
all work in the headless Dart
desktop VM as well as Flutter?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN:
Yeah, the server VM.
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah,
I was demoing it
with the adventure game,
and that's basically
the headless Dart VM.
There's a couple of commits that
need to happen when I get back
to Mountain View.
AUDIENCE: So for IoT development
running Dart VM on IoT devices?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You could do
exactly the same thing?
TODD TURNIDGE: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
TODD TURNIDGE: And
please send us bug
reports if you
find any problems.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
that'd be great.
SPEAKER 3: Should we
do one more question?
Zero more questions?
Let's get it going.
You guys ready
for the next talk?
TODD TURNIDGE:
Thanks a lot, guys.
[APPLAUSE]